[موسيقى]
مساؤكم نحييكم وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء الى عناوينها
النواب الليبي يقيل بشاغه ويحيله الى
التحقيق والمبعوث الامامي يفتح باب الترشح
امام الجميع
كيف تكشف عن مخطط استنزاف قوه روسيا
وفاجنر في ضخمه عبر اشهر من الكر والفر
د
[موسيقى]
مع تجدد الشبكات في الخرطوم طرف الصراع
عاجزين عن حسم المعركه ودرفور ادفع الثمن
الخزانه الامريكيه تحضر من تخلف واشنطن عن
دفع ديونها اذا لم يرفع الكونجرس صدف
[موسيقى]
صوت مجلس النواب الليبيه بالاغلبيه على
ايقاف رئيس الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
فتح بشاغه واحالته لتحقيق وكلف مجلس
النواب الليبي وزير الماليه بالحكومه
المكلفه اسامه حماد بتسيير مهام رئاسه
الحكومه بالاضافه لوزاره الماليه كان
بشاغه بوقت سابق كلف نائبه علي القطران
بتسير مهام مجلس الوزراء قبل ان تحجب
الثقه
واحتراما
المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا دعا
البرلمان لاتفاق على حكومه موحده لاجراء
الانتخابات كما اضاف المجلس ان مهمه
الحكومه المقترحه هو انهاء المرحله
الانتقاليه كما دعا رئيس المجلس التفات
الى مصلحه الدوله العليا على خارطه طريق
الانتخابات
المبعوث الامامي لليبيا عبد الله بتيل شدد
في حوار مع العربي على ضروره اشراك كافه
اصحاب المصلحه بمن فيها القاده ليبيون في
العمليه الانتخابيه مشيرا الى ان
الانتخابات المقبله ستجرى اذا توفرت
الاراده والرغبه لدى كافه الاطراف
وهذه القضايا لاكثر من سنتين
واذا كان هناك
نيه حسنه وكذلك التزام سياسي واخلاقي
حقيقي وكذلك اذا ما اتخذ القرار
بالاستجابه لنداء الشعبي الليبي فلا ارى
اي سبب يمنع عقد هذه الانتخابات وطبعا
الانتخابات لا تقتصر على القانون
الانتخابي وكذلك هي لا تقتصر على
الاتفاقات السياسيه كما انها لا تخص فقط
القاعده الدستوريه وانما تعني اشراك الشعب
الليبي وكذلك كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه
ولذلك قلت بانه ينبغي علينا اشراك كافه
اصحاب المصلحه بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال
القاده الامنيين
وبشان يترشح حفتر وسيف الاسلام القذافي
الانتخابات المقبله قال المبعوث الامامي
لليبيا عبد الله بتيل انه لا يجب ان
يستثنى احد من العمليه الانتخابيه
ما المقاربه الامميه المتعلقه بشروط
الترشح هل من المفترض او من الضروري ان
يسمح للعسكريين ولوجوه النظام السابق بان
يترشحوا للرئاسيات ونقصد هنا بالتاكيد
خليفه حفتر سيف الاسلام القذافي وغيرهم من
الشخصيات بالتاكيد
ادركوا ان سمت قضاي جدليه بما في ذلك
معايير الترشح للانتخابات
ولكن فيما يخص بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم في
ليبيا
الانتخابات حتى تكون
ممثله لاراده الشعب الليبي ومن اجل توصل
الى استقرار بفضل هذه الانتخابات هذه
الانتخابات يجب ان لا تستثني احدا
[موسيقى]
دعونا الان نذهب معكم الى جديد التطورات
الاوكرانيه الروسيه اذا ما تحدثنا عن جبهه
بخمه ام المعارك فخ بخمط انزلقت اليه
روسيا وفق مخطط اوكراني مدروس بعنايه وفقه
صحيفه وولد دعونا اذا نبدا معكم في هذه
الخريطه لنشرح اكثر ونذهب من بخمت نذهب
ونشرح اكثر طبيعه هذه المعارك وهذه
المعركه الممتده منذ اشهر دون حسم لاي من
الطرفين سواء من روسيا اوكرانيا فما الذي
فعلته كييف بالتحديد في هذه المنطقه التي
تقع شرق اوكرانيا بالتحديد كيف بدات اذا
تستنزف قدرات الدفاع الروسيه باصرار عن
بخمه في معركه استمرت عشره اشهر مثلا
عمليات الاستنزاف كانت بمحاصره في
الدبابات التي وصلت طبعا للقوات
الاوكرانيه من مختلف الدول الحلفاء التي
تعتبرها اوكرانيا والتي كانت قدمت لها
ايضا تعرضت عده منا
لقصف كما ايضا في عده مناطق استراتيجيه
هناك تعويل كثير على هذه المنطقه لانه
سيكون هناك نقطه امداد من هذه المنطقه الى
المناطق الاخرى وبالتالي ايضا تعتبر كافه
الاطراف بان السيطره على بخمه هي سيطره
معنويه رمزيه لكل من الطرفين رغم انها لم
تحسم بعد اذا قاده اوكرانيون اكدوا بان
التطورات الاخيره اثبتت نجاح استراتيجيتهم
المتمثله بالتمسك بالمدينه لاطول فتره
ممكنه طبعا كان في هناك اذا سيطره وثبات
حوال هذه المنطقه بالنسبه لباخ اذا تحدثنا
عن التمسك في المدينه طبعا هذا التمسك في
المدينه تمثل
بالسيطره على بعض الكيلومترات كما اعلنت
الجهات الاوكرانيه والتحدث ايضا عن الصمود
من قبل بعض القوات الاوكرانيه في المناطق
المتعدده في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد كان
هناك اذا عمليه وطبعا بطبيعه الحال عمليات
الاستنزاف والمعارك هي تستنزف الجهه
الروسيه وتستنزف الجهتين سواء من حيث
العتاد والعتيد يريد القاده الروس
الاستيلاء على بخمه لاسباب عسكريه ايضا
ياملون ان تشكل المدينه منصه انطلاق نحو
المزيد من المكاسب الميدانيه الهدف اذا
كان الاشتباك واستنفاذ عتاد وعتيد القوات
الروسيه في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد طبعا
منطقه بخموت كان فيها الشبكات مستمره لعده
اشهر وحتى هذه النقطه اذا لم يحسم اي من
الطرفين هذه الجبهه المشتعله جدا في شرق
اوكرانيا والتي تريد ايضا روسيا استكمال
السيطره عليها رغم التضارب الروايات
والمعلومات المتعلقه في هذه المنطقه
بالتحديد طبعا نستكمل معكم جديد الاخبار
المتعلقه بهذه النقطه بالتحديد حيث ان
القوات الروسيه كانت تستعد لشن هجومه في
اماكن اخرى واستضارب الانباء طبعا في
الاسبوع الماضي شنت اوكرانيا هجمات مضاده
مفاجئه كانت مكنتها من استعاده عده
كيلومترات سواء في الضواحي الغربيه لهذه
المدينه طبعا هذه الهجمات والمكاسب
الاوكرانيه كانت خففت من قبضه روسيا على
طرق الامداد الحيويه كما دفعتها لارسال
وحدات اضافيه الى ضواحي المدينه
اعتقد انها لعبه ما لا اظن انها تطابق
الواقع انها تنسجم مع اهدافهم واعتقد ان
حكومتنا تمسك كل شيء قدر المستطاع تحت
السيطره وتفعل وستفعل كل شيء ممكن
هذا مزيف وغير حقيقي
[موسيقى]
انا اعتقد انه خطا ما تم ارتكابه من حيث
تزويدهم بالذخيره ولكن الان تم تصحيحه
لا اساس له من الصحه
اذا في بخمه تكمن المعارك وفي كييف يتردد
صداها الانتقامي فعلى ذوي الانفجارات
استيقظه سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه ليس هذه
المره الاولى بل الثامنه في اقل من 15
يوما حيث نفذت روسيا ثامن هجوم ضخم على
كييف خلال شهر مايو الحالي واستخدمه
صواريخ كروز وطائرات من دون طيار رئيس
الاداره العسكريه لمدينه كييف اكد ان
الغاره استثنائيه في كتافتها مع القائها
اقصى عدد من الصواريخ وفي وقت قصير في
اقصر فتره زمنيه ورجح استخدام القوات
الروسيه للصواريخ الباليستيه في هذه
الغاره الى جانب المسيرات وايضا صواريخ
كروز معظمها تدمر حسب قوله اما وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه فلنتابع ماذا قالت
جنه القوات المسلحه للاتحاد الروسي ضربه
مركزه على مواقع وحدات الجيش الاوكراني
ومواقع تخزين الاسلحه والمعدات المقدمه من
الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا وذلك عبر اسلحه
جويه وبحريه بعيده المدى وقد تحقق الهدف
بعد ضرب جميع المواقع المحدده
نذهب الان الى مراسلي العربيه من كيف
حذيفه عادل ومن دوناتس كرائد الاغبر اهلا
بكما حذيفه معك هل بدا الهجوم المضاد الذي
اعلنت عنه كيف منذ مده
مساء الخير
رائد هذا بالضبط ما يقوله المراقبون
والخبراء العسكريين هنا في العاصمه كيف
بشكل عام الذين يراقبون هذه الحرب وخاصه
المعركه في ضخموت يقولون ان هذا هو الهجوم
المضاد الغير معلن من قبل السلطات
الاوكرانيه ولديها اسبابها طبعا لكي لا
تعلن بشكل رسمي عن ان الهجوم المضاد قد
بدا فعلا قامت القوات الاوكرانيه بهجمات
مضاده في مدينه باخبوت هذه الهجمات كانت
من الاجنحه من الشمال ومن الجنوب وتقدمت
واستطاعت ان تستعيد 10 مواقع في هذه
المناطق اي ما مساحته 20 كيلومترا على
الرغم من ان القوات الروسيه من العمق
استطاعت ان تتقدم قليلا ولكنه تقدم طفيف
جدا ولكن السيطره للقوات الاوكرانيه من
الاجنحه وهنا ايضا الخبراء العسكريين
يقولون ان قد يكون هدف القوات الاوكرانيه
هو عمليه حصار للقوات الروسيه في هذه
المدينه ثم بعد ذلك اما اجبارها على
الانسحاب او تحيد القوه رائد الى
مساء الخير لك ولو حذيفه ايضا بالفعل هناك
هجومات مضاده اوكرانيه يقول جنود ان كان
في محور باخمه او في المحاور الاخرى كمارن
كوارديفيكا بان هناك تقدم في بعض النقاط
للقوات الاوكرانيه لكن هذا التقدم ليس
ملموسا حيث يعني اكدت قوات فاغنر
بالفيديوهات تقدمها ووصولها الى اخر
المدينه حيث البنايات الشاهقه الحديث عن
عشرين مبنى متبقي لاكمال السيطره على
مدينه باقمت وان هذا
التقدم او العوده الاوكرانيه بالهجومات
المضاده كما يعني اسلف زميلي حذيفه هو من
الاجنحه الجناح الجنوبي والجناح الشمالي
وان هذه الاجنحه لا تؤثر على قدره الجيش
الروسي او قوات فاجنر التي باتت تضرب
الجسور والممرات التي توصل الامدادات
العسكريه ان كانت بشريه او بالعتاد للجيش
المتمركز في المنطقه الغ بالفعل اليوم كان
هناك ضرب لجسرين على نهر سيفر سكيدانيه
لمنع الامدادات بالفعل منطقه شسوفير اصبحت
عاجزه عن اصاله الامدادات للقوات
الاوكرانيه وربما الايام القادمه يعني
تظهر لنا سيطره كامله لقوات فاجنر المنطقه
العوده فعلا موجوده للقوات الاوكرانيه
لكنها ليست بالقوه التي يعلن عنها الغرب
او القوات الاوكرانيه هكذا يقول الجنود
هنا على ارض المعارك رائد مره اخرى عودي
لحذيفه ليس فقط الجبهه الشرقيه لاوكرانيا
مشتعله بل قلب العاصمه الاوكرانيه التي ما
زالت تتعرض الى اليوم الى استهدافات روسيا
ما طبيعتها حتى الساعه
نعم صحيح نادين او وصلت حصيله الضربات
الصاروخيه الى سبعه وعشرين صاروخا هذا في
كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه حصيله طبعا اكيد
منها كانت 18 صاروخا اطلقت في الثالثه
والنصف من صباح اليوم نحو العاصمه كيف سته
منها كانت من تراث كينج وكذلك من صواريخ
كروز البحريه والارضيه والاس 4
واسكندر كل هذه الصواريخ اطلقت في مدى زمن
قصير جدا لذلك الضربه كانت الضخمه ولكن
استطاعت الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه كما
افاد الناطق الرسمي باسم سلاح الجو
الاوكراني ان يدمر جميع الاهداف التي وجهت
نحو العاصمه كيف كان هنالك عدد قليل من
الشظايا الذي سقط في داخل المدينه في بعض
المناطق منطقه السلومسكي
ابلونسكي في هذه المناطق سقطت بعد الشظايا
وايضا في حديقه الحيوانات سقطت شظيه ولم
يكن هنالك اضرار تذكر داخل المدينه كان
هنالك ضرر خفيف في منطقه في ضواحي مدينه
كيف في احد المساكن الخشبيه ايضا كان
هنالك اطلاق للمسيرات تزامنا مع اطلاق
الصواريخ وايضا استطاعت الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان تدمر هذه المسيرات بالاضافه
الى الطائرات استطلاع من طراز اون لاين
مره اخرى اليك رائد رائد
ماذا تتحدث بعض التقارير عن ان
المساله ومساله المعارك فيما يتعلق في
الشرق الاوكراني ليست بصالح الروس هذه
المره ماذا يدور في الاجواء
يعني هو سؤال هام جدا انا دين اولا وصول
الاسلحه المتطوره لايدي المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين كان لها تاثيرها حيث بالسابق
هنا في مدينه دانياتك كانت تسقط حوالي 100
قذيفه وصاروخ يوميا على مناطق المدنيين في
قلب المدينه اليوم تصل من 300 الى 500
قذيفه وصاروخ وتسفر عن اصابات وقتله يوميا
هذا اولا ثانيا نوعيه هذه الاسلحه نتحدث
عن سبعه صواريخ
ستورم
البريطانيه نتحدث عن سبعه صواريخ هايبرز
نتحدث ايضا عن ثلاثه صواريخ هارم تطلق من
المقاتلات الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن ظهور
للمقاتلات الاوكرانيه على اطراف الاقليم
هنا في اقليم دمباس هناك بالفعل تقدم
للقوات الاوكرانيه لكن الجانب الروسي يقول
بانه مستعد وانه اعد خطط دفاعيه لمنع هذا
التقدم ولع دم تكرار ما حصل بخساره خرسون
ولمان خلال العام الماضي وانهم يتقدمون
على الاراضي ان كان في
مارينكا او في برفان او حتى في باخموت
يتقدمونه ببطء لكن هو تقدم جزئي ومنع لهذه
العمليات المضاده الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا
لكما رائد الاغبر ومن كيف حذيفه عادل
بعد وصول الاسلحه المتطوره الغربيه من
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا الى ارض الحرب
في اقليم دومباس اختلفت وتيره المعارك على
جبهات عده واهمها مقاطعه التي تشهد معارك
وهجمات اوكرانيه مضاده ضد الجيش الروسي
تشهد معارك الازمه الاوكرانيه تقلبات
عديده تسببت بهزيمه طرف في حال نقص
الذخيره ونصر الطرفا اخر في حال وفره
السلاح لذلك توجهنا الى اطراف مدينه
مارينكا المحتدمه بالمعارك لرصد مزيد من
الاخبار حول الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد مع
بدء الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه في مناطق
مختلفه من مقاطعه دانياتك ارتفعت وتيره
القصف المتبادل ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والجيش الروسي ومع اقترابنا من هذه
المناطق التي تعتبر اطراف مدينه مارينكا
ذات المعارك الساخنه والمحتدمه ما بين
الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه العوده بهجمات مضاده ومحاوله
استرجاع
كان قد سيطر عليها جيش الروسي سابقا
ومع احتدام هذه المعارك بين جيشين الروسي
والاوكراني يحاول الجيش الروسي اتخاذ
وسيله الدفاع بعد ان تاكد من وصول الاسلحه
والذخيره الى ايدي المقاتلين الاوكراني من
مدينه مارنكا التقينا مع المقاتلين في هذا
المحور
تحت سيطرتنا مساحات كبيره هنا اما بخصوص
الهجوم مضاده ومحاوله استرجاع اراضي كان
قد سيطر عليها جيش الروسي سابقا
ومع احتدام هذه المعارك بين جيشين الروسي
والاوكراني يحاول الجيش الروسي اتخاذ
وسيله الدفاع بعد ان تاكد من وصول الاسلحه
والذخيره الى ايدي المقاتلين الاوكران من
مدينه مارينكا التقينا مع المقاتلين في
هذا المحور
تحت سيطرتنا مساحات كبيره هنا اما بخصوص
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي تعلن عنه
كييف استطيع القول انها دعايه اكثر من
الحقيقه حيث نتعرض لهجمات في عده جبهات
باستمرار وهذه طبيعه المعارك والحروب وبكل
الاحوال نصد الهجمات ونتقدم ببطء لعده
امتار يوميا لانهم يتحصلون جيدا ومستعدون
ومجهزون لكننا نتقدم ولو ببطء ونحن واثقون
من النصر وقريبا سنحرر مدينه مارينكا
بالكامل
من خطوط الجبهه الاماميه ومن
خانه الروسيه حيث الدبابات والمدافع التي
تطلق من حولنا هنا
نرصد العربيه والحدث المعارك التي تدور في
اطراف مارنكا
بقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
مارينكا
[موسيقى]
كشف محققون اوكرانيون عن تسجيل فساد واسع
النطاق في المحكمه العليا الوطنيه المكتب
الوطني لمكافحه الفساد باوكرانيا قال ان
بعض القضاه في المحكمه العليا حصلوا على
مكاسب غير مشروعه اعلام اوكرانيون قال ان
رئيس المحكمه العليا
اعتقل الاشتباه في تلقي رشوه بقيمه ثلاثه
ملايين دولار السلطات الاوكرانيه نشرت
صوره لاكوام من الدولارات مصفوفه على
اريكه كشفه على ان حجز هذه الاموال جاء
بعد تحقيقات اجراها مكتب محاربه الفساد
ومكتب المدعي العام الخاص بمكافحه الفساد
واوكرانيا التي تحتل المرتبه 116 من بين
180 دوله في مؤشر الفساد العالمي لمنظمه
شفافيه دوليه تواجه ضغوطا متزايده لمواجهه
الفساد المستشري في عدد من مؤسساتها تعمل
على اصلاح نظامها القضائي والتصدي للرشوه
والكسب غير المشروع تسعى الحكومه
الاوكرانيه الى بدء محادثات بحلول نهايه
العام بشان الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
غير انها تحتاج اولا الى تلبيه العديد من
المتطلبات الاوروبيه يتعلق معظمها بمعالجه
الفساد
في هذا الوقت تم اعتقال رئيس المحكمه
العليا ويجري اتخاذ تدابير للتحقق من
الاشخاص الاخرين وتورطهم في الجريمه
الجنائيه
مستمره ونتابع في سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
الاقتصاد والزلزال اوراقه كلتش
[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا المساء على
شاشه العربيه كشفت الولايات المتحده عن
ارقام ترسمتها الاستراتيجيه للردع النووي
واكده انها تريد احترام معاهده
لنزع السلاح النووي اكدت انها كانت تنشر
في الاول من مارس الماضي
62 صاروخا بلتيا عابرا للقارات وهو عدد
يشمل الصواريخ المنصوبه في الغواصات
والطائرات القاذفه مزود بالف واربع مئه
وتسعه عشر راسا نوويه و800 قاذفه وضعت
الخارجيه الامريكيه روسيا التي علقت
مشاركتها في المعاهده الى فعل المثل
واحترام واجباتها القانونيه بالعوده
للمعاهده واجراءات الاستقرار والشفافيه
التي تحويها
استغلاله عدم رضا بعض الروس عن سياسات
رئيسهم فلاديمير بوتين محور احدث تحركا
استراتيجيا امريكيا واستخباراتيا حيث تخطط
واشنطن لتجنيد الروس الناقمين على وضع
بلادهم الحالي بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
الفيديو الذي انتشر على تيليجرام غاز
الرافدين لبوتين وحظهم على تزويده
بمعلومات استخباريه عن رئيسهم وحكومتهم
لتحسين اوضاعهم كما اطلعهم على كيفيه فعل
ذلك دون الكشف عن هويتهم او المتصفحات
وادوات تشفير الاتصالات التي يمكن
استخدامها
تخاطب المواطنين الروس مقطع من دقيقتين
نشرته عبر المنصه الروسيه تيليجرام تحض
خلاله الروس على كشف معلومات عن بلادهم
المقطع يظهر عائله روسيه محبطه من سياسه
بوتين المحتوى يحاول التاكيد على الحس
الوطني للعائله ويشجع الروس للافصاح عن
معلومات في مختلف المجالات الوكاله في
الفيديو قالت نريد معرفه حقيقه في روسيا
وتبعث سي اي اي رساله بالروسيه مفادها
نبحث عن اشخاص موثوقين للادلاء بشهاداتهم
الاستخبارات شددت على توفير منفذ امن
للمتحدثين مصادر قالت ان الدعايه واشنطن
لا تهدف لتغيير النظام في موسكو
[موسيقى]
الكاريزما السياسيه وفقه كثيرين ادت لتفوق
رجب طيب اردوغان على منافسه رئيسي كمال
كلتش وتحديا امال المعارضه بالفوز الكبير
رغم امال رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري بتحقيق
مفاجاه بجوله الاعاده حددت صحيفه فاينل
تايمز البريطانيه العقبات الجاثمه امامه
بثلاثه اولها ارهاق الناخبين المعارضين
وفقدانهم للحافز بعد نتائج كانت اسوا من
المتوقع اما ثاني التحديات فمن داخل
المعارضه اي التشكيك بان كلتش دار اوغلو
هو المنافس المناسب لمواجهه اردوغان فكل
حزب الشعب الجمهوري ل 13 عاما دون ان
ينتصر في اي انتخابات شرعيه او حتى رئاسيه
لكن العقبه الاهم تتمثل بالحصول على اصوات
المرشحه الرئاسي القومي سنان اوغان الذي
حصد اكثر من 5% من اصوات الناخبين في
الجوله الاولى لكن ميله لاردوغان اكثر
ترجيحا الى ان خبراء سبقوا جوله الاعاده
بالتاكيد ان المشهد السياسي التركي سيظل
دون تغيير تقريبا
[موسيقى]
الى اسطنبول ومعنا من هناك كريستيانو
بيصري موفده العربيه يسعد مساكي كريستيانو
اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء بدايه
ما الجديد تحركات كل من المرشحين لاستماله
او استقطاب اصوات الناخب
قبل ان نتحدث عن تحركاتهم اود ان ابدا معك
بتصريحاتهم التي صدرت منذ قليل حقيقه
اردوغان لا يزال يتحدث حتى الان الى وسيله
اعلام محليه
واغان انها حديثه منذ قليل اردوغان اعترف
بانهم لم ينالوا نفس نسبه الاصوات كما في
الانتخابات الماضيه
ولكنه بالمقابل هاجم كثيرا المعارضه تحدث
عن قضيه محاولتهم لاستماله
مواطني اماكن الزلزال وكيف عندما لم
يتمكنوا من ذلك بداوا بمهاجمتهم وقالوا
بانهم يستمتعون بالبقاء في الخيام
وغيرها من التصريحات التي يعني فقدها
اردوغان وقال بانهم ينتقدون هؤلاء لانهم
اعطوني اصواتهم وقال بانه سيكون له جوله
يومي السبت والاحد على هذه المناطق
المنكوبه تعرضت للسلسال كما تطرق ايضا الى
قضيه
تحالف المعارضه مع ما اسماه المنظمات
الارهابيه في اشاره الى حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الكردي
وايضا تحدث عن ضروره تجانس السلطه
التشريعيه وتنفيذيه في اشاره الى كسب حزبه
او التحالفه تحالف
الجمهور الانتخابات البرلمانيه
وضروره ان يعني يكسب ايضا الرئاسه ليكون
هناك تناغم بين السلطتين التشريعيه
والتنفيذيه وبالتالي خطابه
ركز على نقاط ضعف المعارضه بالمقابل خطاب
سنان اوغان تحدث عن ان المشاورات لا تزال
جاريه مع الطرفين مع اردوغان ومع كلو ولكن
حتى الان لم يتم حسم اي شيء لم يتم التوصل
الى اي
اتفاقات بين بين بين احد الطرفين وقال
بانهم اذا لم يلبوا شروطنا الا وهل وهي
قضايا معالجه الاقتصاد والحفاظ على المواد
الاولى من الدستور المتعلقه بالحفاظ على
القوميه التركيه وايضا قضيه فك الارتباط
معا التنظيمات الارهابيه في اشاره الى
الاكراد وترحيل ما يعتقد انه 13 مليون
لاجئ كل هذه الشروط قال سنان اوغان اذا لم
يحققها اي من الطرفين بالتالي قد لا نذهب
الى تحالف مع اي منهما لاننا تهمنا
مبادئنا وليس فقط مصالحنا كما انه اشار
ايضا الى ان
الطرفين يجب ان ينتبها الى ان من يحسم
ايضا الجوله الثانيه ليس فقط نعم اصوات
التي نالها سنان اوغان وانما كذلك ثمانيه
ملايين
يعني مسجل لم يتوجهوا الى صناديق الاقتراع
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الاحاطه لصنبول
كريستيان بيصري مفردات العربيه الى هناك
الاتراك لعبوا ورقه الاستقرار والامن
بالجوله الاولى اي انهم رفضوا وضع ثقتهم
بتحالف معارض متعدد الاطراف والمصالح
استطلاعات الراي الاوليه جاءت خادعه فقد
اظهرت ان الناخبين على وشك اداره ظهورها
لنزعه رجب طيب اردوغان الاستبداديه الى ان
هذا التفاؤل كان في غير محل فالازمه
الاقتصاديه والزلزال المدمر ورقه
الاساسيتان لم تفلحا وتحققا الاثار
المتوقعه على الرغم من الاقتصاد المتعثر
اظهر تصويت ارتخاء قبضه اردوغان على
السلطه ولكن ليس انكسارها صحيفه غارديان
البريطانيه اكدت ان المعارضه ستحتاج الى
شق طريقها بين الناخبين الوطنيين الاقل
ثراء خارج المدن للنجاح بجوله الاعاده
سينما ان مهمه التحالف كلتش دار اوغلو
صعبه للغايه معا حياز وسائل الاعلام
باغلبيه ساحقه لصالح اردوغان وعقد ثالث من
حكمه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى اسطنبول معلم هناك الكاتب الصحفي
اسلام اوسكان اهلا بك السيد اسلام معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء بعد الحديث عن ان
المرشح الثالث في الانتخابات سنان اوغان
هو مفتاح الدور الثاني وجوله الاعاده
بالتالي لمن ستذهب اصوات في جوله الاعاده
اصلا اصوات سنانو كان ليس المفتاح الوحيد
يعني هناك من لا يدلي باصواتهم اما
احتجاجا على الوضع الحالي ام اما
بسبب الله مبالاه او لاسباب عديده لذلك
ثلاث ملايين شخص يعني سيكون هدف الرئيسي
بالنسبه لحزب الشعب الجمهوري وتحالف الامه
وايضا هناك
اليوم يعني في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وفي وسائل اعلام المعارضه
بدات بعض الاصوات تعلو فيما يتعلق
بالتزويرات
والخداعات وايضا الاشياء يعني غير جيده
الضغط على حزب الشعب الجملي وعلى اشتروا
من اجل الذهاب الى
مبنى او مقر
هيئه العليا هيئه الانتخابات العليا
التركيه لان بدات المعلومات بل المعطيات
تاتي الى الاحزاب المعارضه
فجاه هناك مفاجاه كبيره جدا هناك تناقضات
فيما يتعلق بنتائج التي صرحت بها هيئه
الانتخابات العليا ام هذه التجاذبات الم
تضعف من حماسه الناخب التركي في جوله
الاعاده
طبعا يعني معنويات انصار حزب العادات هو
التنميه
يعني مرتفع اكثر بكثير مقارنه مع تحالف
الامه
والتفوق السيكولوجي والتفوق النفسي ايضا
بيد حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان هذا شيء واضح ولكن اليوم
اظن يعني بعد اجتماع طويل جدا
كريشتروا مع
نائبيه او نوابه او مع مساعديه
وخاصه مع اكرام امام منصوريه اتخذوا
قرارات مهمه جدا يعني تم طرد المسؤول عن
المراقبه العامه في الحزب وتم ابعاد ايضا
المسؤول العام بالنسبه للعلاقات مع يعني
بي ار بابل كروليشنز وايضا هناك اتخذ
قرارات مهمه جدا لذلك على ما يبدو ان
المعارضه المعارضه بشكل عام تحالف الامه
بحاجه الى نقطتين النقطه الاولى فكر جديد
مفاجئ جدا وسوف يتاثر منها حزب يعني عفوا
الشعب التركي بشكل عام او داخلين الاتراك
بالشكل العام
والشيء الثاني والنقطه الثانيه هي
وضع استراتيجيه جديده سوف يخلق جوا مناسبا
لتمهيد الطريق للتوصل الى الفوز وتحقيق
انتصار هذا الشيء ممكن نحن رايناها في عده
مدن يا عفوا في عده بلدان في العالم مثلا
في كوستاريكا في الحقيقه العديد من
التساؤلات ولكن الوقت انت شكرا جزيلا لك
من اسطنبول كاتب الصحفي اسلام اوسكان
[موسيقى]
محاولات للحسم السريع والسيطره كامله باءت
بالفشل من قبل الطرفين لينتهي الشهر الاول
من الاشتباكات بتقاسم السيطره حتى اللحظه
المواجهات المسلحه لا تتزال تتركز فيها
الخرطوم وبحر واندرمان لثقالها السياسي
بالنسبه للطرفين واحتوائها على مواقع
حيويه واستراتيجيه ومقر حكوميه خريطه
السيطره الحاليه قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر
على 80% من مدن الخرطوم وفق تقارير صحفيه
حيث تنتشر بالقصر الجمهوري ومحيط القياده
العامه للجيش ومطار الخرطوم الدولي وسط
استمرار للمعارك في هذه النقاط كما توجد
ايضا مجاميع عربات الدعم السريع العسكريه
بمصفاه الجيلي للبترول ومحطه المياه
الرئيسيه بمدينه بحري عند هذه النقطه
وايضا مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون الرسمي
باندرمان عند هذه النقطه اشكاليه الجيش
الان في العاصمه تتمثل بصعوبه نشره طبعا
البريه التي تعرضت اكثر من مره للضرب
وتشتت قبل وصولها الى الخرطوم فيما نشاطه
الجوي مستمر بهدف قطع طرق امداد قوات
الدعم السريع حرب الجسور العشره ايضا
محتدمه ويسيطر الجيش على جسور الحلفايه
وايضا جسر النيل الابيض والانقاذ وكوبر
والمنشيه الابيض فيما تفرط قوات الدعم
السريع تفرض سيطره على جسور شامبات وتوتي
وايضا سوبا في ممك النمر تسيطر عليه كل
جهه من كل طرف من كل جهه افضليه مؤقته
للجيش في الجسور وسيطر على كل عواصم
الولايات السودانيه عدا ولايات دارفور
الخمس وايضا العاصمه الخرطوم هناك ايضا
فول قاعده خلفيه لامداد قوات الدعم السريع
فيما اذا ذهبنا غربا تعتبر مدينه
المطله على البحر الاحمر بمثابه الرئه
وايضا المتنفس الاساسي لنظام الخرطوم
وتمده بالعتاد والعتيد
نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك الصحفي
عمار ابو شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء ما جديد الوضع
الميداني خاصه في ظل المعلومات التي تتحدث
عن تقدم الجيش في منطقه الكادرو
اهلا بك نادين واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم الجديد الان على ارض الواقع بشكل واضح
كنا قبل نصف ساعه من الان ننعم بعدد
النسبي للهدوء نسبه مقدره باعتبارنا
المعارك كانت منذ الصباح الباكر وحتى اخر
النهار بدات من جديد دوري المدافع
والانفجارات هنا في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
وفي منطقه بحري ايضا كذلك وهذه المناطق
التي تشهد معارك مستعره منذ الصباح الباكر
وحتى
اخر النهار ومن ثم عادت من جديد هذه
الانفجارات قبل لحظات من الدخول لهذا
المباشر منطقه الكادرو او معسكر سواقه
بمنطقه الشمال بحري دارت فيه معركه كبيره
ما بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريعه التي امتدت الى تلك المنطقه
باعتبارنا الجيش كان يؤمن تلك المنطقه منذ
الايام الاولى لعمر هذه الحرب الجيش في
بيان له اشار الى انه تصدى من خلال
الشمال لهذه القوات القوات الدعم السريع
في المنطقه بانها شنت هجوما عليه في صباح
هذا اليوم قوات الدعم السريع بالجانب
الاخر تحدثت واشارت في بيان وعدد من الصور
والفيديوهات الى انها تمكنت من اسرع عدد
من الجنود والسيطره على هذه المناطق
العسكريه ولكن الجيش ايضا في بيان اخر
اشار ونشر فيديو معلنا فيه النصر في هذه
المنطقه واحتفاء ما بين الجماهير
المتواجدين بالقرب من هذه المنطقه وايضا
كذلك الجنود منطقه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
دارت فيها عده معارك في منطقه جبرا وغربي
او جنوبي العاصمه الخرطوم على وجه التحديد
ومنطقه ايضا كذلك احياء الصحافه ومنطقه
العمارات شارع 61 حيث هنالك دارت معركه
ايضا بريه ومواجهه مباشره في هذه المنطقه
ونلاحظ فيها قبل لحظات ربما السنه اللهب
في هذا المعسكر التابع للجيش السوداني
ايضا كذلك الطيران الحرب التابع للجيش قصف
هذه المنطقه باعتبار ان القوات الدعم
السريع تمددت الى هذه المنطقه ودارت فيها
المعركه البريه من جديد تعود طائرات
الاستطلاع للتحليق في هذه اللحظات مع
سويدا مع الانفجارات في عدد من المناطق
خلصت العاصمه الخرطوم ومدينه بحرين شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الاحاطه عمار ابو شيبه
الصحفيين الخرطوم
بعد خروج المنظمات العامله في الحقل
الانساني بمعسكرات النزوح باقليم دارفور
شكى عدد من النازحين بمعسكر النيم شرق
دارفور منعدام المساعدات وعدم القدره على
الحصول على المياه والمستلزمات الصحيه
اللازمه
[موسيقى]
نتواجد اليوم هنا في معسكر النيم للنازحين
بولايه شرق دارفور وهو احد معسكرات اقليمي
دارفور للنازحين الازمه السودانيه الدائره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع الغت باظلالها
على واقع المعسكر خاصه بعد خروج عدد كبير
من المنظمات العامله في الحقل الانساني
كما نتابع هنالك تكدس كبير جدا في موارد
المياه بسبب نقص الوقود وايضا بسبب عدم
وجود تشغيل لهذه المحطات التي تعمل في
مجال السقيا للمعسكر هنالك معاناه ايضا في
شتى المجالات الصحيه والانسانيه
بس دمعه دمويه الزحمه دي عدم المويه اذا
كان المويه في الزحمه ما بيكون فيه
ويضم معسكر النيم للنازحين ما يزيد عن 100
الف نازح يتوزعون في مربعات محدوده يعانون
نقصا في الغذاء والدواء بسبب تدهور
الاوضاع في السودان بعد الاحداث التي حصلت
فيهم 15 الى يومنا هذا اصبح المواطن في
معسكر النيل في مستوى واحد
كله مستوى واحد لانهم تحت السفر من حيث
المعاناه لا وجود لاي حركه بالدخل ولا في
مدخل ولا حتى الناس اللي شويه عندهم يعني
حبه اعمال تجاره شنو برضو وقفت الان
معاناه بشكل يساوي 99 وتسعه وعشرين اي كل
كما يتخوف سكان المعسكر من الانفلات
الامني خاصه عمليات السلب والنهب التي
يستخدم فيها السلاح والله حصل نشوف جدا
والمواطنين فرو وواديين ماتوا وبدات البلد
تعبانه وما فيها ناس
يستقروا والله
من هنا ايضا
اذا لم تعود الاوضاع في السودان الى
الواقع الذي كانت عليه ربما يتوسع شبح
المجاعه ليشمل المدن والاحياء التي تعاني
الان في جوانب عديده بجانب معسكرات النزوح
الممتده في عدد من المدن باقليم دارفور
رص
د الاوروبيه والامريكيه العالقين بمدينه
العسكريه التي دخلت شهرها الثانيه
من اسبوعين جينا هنا في بورسودان وجين هنا
كون عشان يشيلونه يودونا
بلداننا وما في اي حاجه حاصله
300 شخص
سفارات بريطانيه امريكيه فرنسيه كل
الجاليات الاوروبيه موجوده هنا طالبنا
سفاراتنا بانه تجلينا لانه في كانوا ناس
قبل كده ونحن كنا عالقين لغايه ما وصلنا
لغايه هنا خاطبنا
نحن حسب بنطالب تاني السفارات الناتج لنا
كل 300 شخص
وكل العالم ده يعلم بها رسالتنا رساله
واحده دارينا الامم المتحده تجلينا لدوله
امنه
دانت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اقتحام
سفاره الاردن بالسودان ومقر سكن رئيس
المكتب العسكري في سفاره الكويت بالخرطوم
اعرب الخارجيه السعوديه عن رفض المملكه
لكل اشكال العنف والتخريب تجاه البعثات
والممثليات الدبلوماسيه وطالبت الاطراف
السودانيه تكافه التزامه بالتهدئه وفق
نتائج مباحثات جدا الاخيره والانخراط في
المسارات السياسيه التي تسعى للوصول الى
حلا عادلا وشاملا للازمه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
تاسع هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في سياقها
ولكن بعد قليل
[تصفيق]
سخريه وانتقاد من الجمهوريين لترشح كماله
هاريس مجددا الى جانب بايدن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا
المساء وفيها الاقتصاد الامريكي والنظام
المالي العالمي بالكامل مهددان فالولايات
المتحده قد تتعثر ولاول مره في سداد
ديونيا في يونيو المقبل التعثر التاريخي
حذرت منه وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه كما
اكدت المخاوف نفسها تقرير مكتب ميزانيه
بواحد وثلاثين تريليون و400 مليار دولار
هي مرهونه حاليا برفع الكونجرس لسقف الدين
او تعليقه قبل ذلك التاريخ اي خلال
اسبوعين قد دعى بايدن رئيس مجلس النواب
وزعماء اخرين في الكونجرس الى البيت
الابيض للصباع المقبل لمناقشه سقف الديون
علما بان مجلس النواب مرر الاسبوع الماضي
مشروع قانوني لرفع سقف الدين العام مقترن
بخفض حاد في نفقات الميزانيه انتقل مشروع
القرار للغرفه العليا في مجلس الشيوخ لكن
في حال فشل الكونجرس في اقراره قد تجد
وزاره الخزانه نفسها غير قادره على سداد
فواتيرها حاول الجمهوريون المسيطرون على
مجلس النواب باغلبيه ضئيله الاستفاده من
الموعد النهائي الذي يلوح في الافق
بانتزاع تخفيضات الانفاق وغيرها من
التنازلات السياسيه من البيت الابيض
اذا ما هي ازمه سقف الديون تم وضع سقف
الدين في عام
1917 لتمويل الحرب العالميه الاولى من
خلال تجميع السندات المختلفه في عام
1939 مع اقتراب الحرب العالميه الثانيه
انشا الكونجرس اول سقف اجمالي للديون وتم
رفع السقف ثمان وسبعين مره منذ عام
1960 بما في ذلك 20 مره منذ عام
2001 عاده ما يرفع الكونجرس او يعلق سقف
الدين قبل الوصول اليه وعاده يقوم الحزب
الذي خرج من السلطه بلقاء اللوم على الطرف
الاخر في تبديره عام 2021 تم رفع حد السقف
ليصل الى 31 تريليون دولار وهو ما يعني
انه لا يجب ان يزيد اجمالي قروض الحكومه
الامريكيه عن هذا الحد في حال بلوغ سقف
الدين الحد الاقصى فان ذلك يعني ان
الحكومه الفيدراليه لن تستطيع الحصول على
قروض جديده وهو ما يجعلها تتخلف عن تنفيذ
التزاماتها التي تتضمن سداد الديون
السابقه
[موسيقى]
تريد
الخلاف بين الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب وانائبه لا يزال متواصلا مع اقتراب
موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله كشفت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن استراتيجيه
الجديده والتي سيسعى من خلالها لاثبات
وجودي في الساحه السياسيه كرجل مناسب
وخيار فريد لقياده الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده المنافسه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري تجتد لنيل الثقه للترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله فالطريق لنيل
لقب سيد البيت الابيض لن يكون يسيرا هذه
المره مع دخول نائب الرئيس الامريكيه
السابق مايك بينس خط المواجهه وتكثيف
تحركاته القائمه على تصيد اخطاء الرئيس
ترامب وفق تقرير صادر عن صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز سيحاول بينس من خلال تحالف السوبر
باك اعتماد استراتيجيه تظهره كرجل مناسب
وخيار فريد لقياده الولايات المتحده
واعاده الحزب الجمهوري الى ايام ما قبل
ترامب حيث سيعمل بانس في حملته الانتخابيه
التي سيتم الاعلان عنها في الاسابيع
المقبله على الضغط مره اخرى على الحوار
الوطني والتركيز على كسب الناخبين
الانجيليين
بعد سخريه من عمق بايدن وترشحه لرئاسه
مجددا سهام الجمهوريين تتوجه الى نائبته
اليوم او من باتت توصف بوظته المحتمله حيث
يسخر الجمهوريون ومنتقدون البيت الابيض من
كمال هاريس لترشحها مجددا الى جانب رئيس
جو بايدن في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره
في نوفمبر 202
قد تصبح بين ليله وضحاها رئيسه للبلاد لا
سيما بايدن تجاوز عتبه 80 من عمره السفيره
الامريكيه السابقه لدى الامم المتحده نيكي
هيلي اوضحت ان تصويت لبايدن يعني على ارض
الواقع الاعتماد على هاريس كرئيسه ووصفت
فكره بلو بايدن 86 عاما حين نهايه ولايته
انفاز بالامر غير المحتمل فيما ذهب
جمهوريون اخرون
كسنتورز الى تشكيك بقدره كماله هاريس على
مواجهه رؤساء كبوتن او نظيره السيني ان
صعدت لرئاسه فجاه اضافه منتقد حارس وبينهم
ديمقراطيون ان الوريثه المحتمله لبايدن
غير مستعده للمستقبل اداره البلاد وقد لا
تنال قضاياها استحسان الناخبين
[موسيقى]
اسهم رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشه سوناك
ليست عاليه وسط البريطانيين وفق احدث
استطلاع لراي اجرته شركه الابحاث يوغوف
اذا
59% من البريطانيين لا يؤيدون السنرك
ولديهم مواقف سلبيه تجاهه بينما يتمتع
زعيم المعارضه ورئيس حزب العمال كير بموقع
افضل قليلا من سونيك مع نسبه تاييد فقط
35% من المستطلعين اما حزب العمال فاحتل
مركزا اعلى من حزب المحافظين الحاكم في
الاستطلاع بنسبه تاييدا بلغت 41 في المئه
مقابل 22 في المئه فقط للمحافظين اجريت
عمليه المسح في الرابع عشر والخامس عشر من
مايو الحالي وكان شارك فيها اكثر من الفي
شخص
[موسيقى]
يريد ان يتعامل بلطف مع بكين فرن بوليسي
قالت
مؤسس شركه فولك يامل بان تجد رسالته
المؤيده للصين تاييدا اكثر مما كانت عليه
عام 2020 الملياردير تايوان يخوض ترشحه
مبكرا لانتخابات رئاسيه بالغه الاهميه
العمل المقبل من شانها اعاده تشكيل النظام
العالمي كما تقول
اعلن الشهر الماضي انه سيسعى للحصول على
ترشيح للرئاسه التايوانيه من حزب المعارضه
الرئيسي في البلاد كومنتاج مقدمه نفسها
على انه افضل مرشح لتجنب الحرب مع الصين
فشلاقوه في الفوز في الانتخابات التمهيديه
لحزب عام 2019 ثم ترك الحزب بعد ذلك وتنقل
التنفيذي لمعها تايوان العالمي ومقر
واشنطن قوله ان الملياردير غو يصوروا نفسه
على انه النسخه التايوانيه لدون الترامب
لكنه على عكس ترامب لم ينجح جو بعد في
محاوله الفوز بالرئاسه حيث يقول خبراء انه
بعيد المنال هذه المره ايضا
[موسيقى]
نسيانه الابتسام او ما وصفوه بصدا تعابير
الوجه معضله تواجه عشرات اليابانيين بعد
ثلاث سنوات من ارتداء الاقنعه واخفاء
الجزء السفلي من الوجه في ظل جائحه كورونا
فكان اليابان نسوا كيفيه تحريك عضلات
الوجه ما فتح المجال امام اختصاصات جديده
ان صح التعبير كمدربي الابتسامه ومتخصصين
بعمل عضلات الوجه بهدف استعاده الابتسامه
واعاده تعلمها هؤلاء هم الاكثر انشغالا
حاليا تحت شعار ابتسامات اكثر سعاده اكبر
المشي على الشواطئ الرمليه او تطاير الشعر
بالهواء لم يعد بالرومانسيه المعهوده بل
خرق خطير للخصوصيه ومعلومات الشخص
البيولوجيه حيث توصل علماء الى امكانيه
سحب الحمض النووي البشري من الهواء او من
اثر الاقدام على الشاطئ او حتى من مياه
المحيطات هذه التقنيه تقوم على استخدام
الحمض النووي الذي تسرب الى البيئه من
خلال البصق والجلد والشعر والعرق والدم
وهو ذو جوده عاليه وفق العلماء وتستخدم
اساسا للمساعده في تتبع الحيوانات المهدده
بالانقراض وحمايتها كالسلاحف البحريه اما
اهميه هذه التقنيه تكمن في امكانيه مطابقه
المعلومات الجينيه للعثور على الاشخاص
المفقودين والمساعده في تحقيقات الطب
الشرعي لحل الجرائم ولتحديد المواقع ذات
الاهميه الاثريه غير ان اثارا سلبيه عده
تترتب على جمع وتحليل البيانات الجينيه
التفصيليه من كل هذه الاماكن تتمثل
بانتهاكات قد تكون غير مقصوده للخصوصيه
تتبع الموقع وجمع البيانات والمراقبه
الجينيه للافراد او الجمعات دون موافقه
مسبقه
الى هنا تنتهي نشره التاسعه هذا المساء
وهذه عناوينها
النواب الليبي يقيل بشاغه ويحيل الى
التحقيق والمبعوث الامامي يفتح باب الترشح
امام الجميع
[موسيقى]
كيف تكشف عن مخطط الاستئناف في قوه روسيا
مع تجدد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم طرفات
صراعه
ودرفور تدفع الثمن
الخزانه الامريكيه تحذر من تخلف واشنطن عن
دفع ديونها اذا لم يرفع الكومبريس
التاسعه هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبارنا
بالتاكيد مستمره بعد قليل نشره 360 وساعه
اخباريه مختلفه معك يا راويه مساء الخير
مساء الخير نادين سنتابع تحضيرات مرشحي
الرئاسات التركيه
والتحضيرات بالاضافه طبعا الى كيف يمكننا
تبيان الكذب من الحقيقه في النتائج
المحققه على الارض في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تابعينا اليك شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات